uh let's switch it up okay you're a
Vegas guy
all-time great give me your top four
Vegas strip clubs of all time open
closed
I'll throw one out first let's go with
strip hop that strip hop error was
special that's seamless it was at like
was it seamless right there off of art
yeah yeah I remember it everybody used
to slide through that [ __ ]
Franny was DJing and I remember that
[ __ ] it was cool Rick Ross and
me sliding yeah yeah it used to pop I
remember that joint um
Palomino's a classic Palomino is a class
in the north the south north is right
there next to a little small spot named
Chicas Bonitas oh yeah that sits right
next to it I believe little small holes
experiment rhinos probably like the
pyramid rhinos Spearmint Rhino good
wings
that's like the tourist spot you know um
ice always I always used to love me some
Crazy Horse Crazy Horse back in the day
or the new one the new one yeah
the new one's got good suits that went
on Industrial for years is that the one
under the bridge yeah under the bridge
they tried to reopen it yeah and then
something [ __ ] happened and they yeah
they weighed with it what else um
Hustler's cool I guess how's it solid
they're solid they're all right I like
the little rooftop [ __ ] the rooftop was
a Vibe when they first opened and they
were throwing parties and [ __ ] I think
baby Dash hosting some [ __ ] up there
yeah sure top was a Vibe yeah 100